[Music]
so I now like to begin the final
speaking session of today's program and
it's my great pleasure to introduce
someone you've already heard from
through her questions that's Marci
Greenwood Marcis I think for many of you
here who know her she's one of these
unusual people where after you've met
them once for about an hour you feel
like this is a really close friend so
here's a special warmth which she
communicates instantly this is in spite
of the fact in my own case that when I
first met her here at MIT Ernie had a
co-op her trip almost the first thing
she says to me as she says Oh Bob she
says this is stealing from a lawyer
variant of this joke how do you tell the
difference between a dead hog on a
highway and a dead being on the highway
and the answer of course is that the hog
is the one with the skid marks anyway in
spite of that part of that beginning
with Marcy never told us we've since in
fact I think become quite good friends
at least from my side anyway Marcy as
you know as you heard earlier is the
Associate Director for science at the
Office of Science and Technology Policy
at the White House and works very
closely with Jack Gibbons and as you
also know played a central role in
producing this document science and the
national interest
Marcie's background before coming to the
government was purely in academia she
began as a undergraduate at Vassar was a
graduate student at at Rockefeller
that's right then went from Rockefeller
to Columbia from Columbia to Vassar
where a vast machining of being I guess
chairman of the department of Vassar and
a chair professor she then went from
Vassar to UC Davis where she became Dean
of Graduate Studies was there for I
guess for years as a Dean so Dean's joke
had content she has a distinguished
research career in developmental cell
biology genetics physiology and
nutrition and specifically she's done
work which has been really wildly
heralded leadership research on genetic
causes of obesity
she's been highly recognized that lots
of awards including among other things
two years ago election to the Institute
of Medicine of the National Academy and
that's a great pleasure to welcome Parsi
to chair this session thank you very
much Bob it's really a great pleasure to
be back here at MIT and it does does
he's just convinced me that I should
stop telling my Dean jokes maybe I
should go back to lawyers cuz these come
these keep coming back to haunt me Jack
Jack's talked about the crook on the D
on the shepherd's staff and now I've had
to hear about the dead hog again in the
in the interests of preserving a good
discussion this afternoon on this topic
that we're going into now which is
extremely important and reflects on two
of the goals that were articulated by
science and the national interest and
that is producing the finest scientists
and engineers for the next century and
in developing a scientifically literate
and technologically competent public
workforce the title of today's session
this afternoon is education for our
future industrial needs I guess I would
argue that we are talking in broad terms
at least about education for our future
nation national needs economically in
industry and also of course as the
bedrock of the academic environment as
well we're going to have four speakers
and I'm going to confine any comments
that I have to some wrap-up comments at
the end of the session so that we have
an opportunity to hear fully from the
for individuals who are with us this
afternoon at the end of a long day I
think it's best to get those who have
come with their minds fully prepared to
share their thoughts with us up forward
and then those of us who primarily came
to listen and learn namely myself to
have an opportunity perhaps to point out
some commonalities between the
perspectives expressed and those of us
who are trying to work productively with
the external communities to build this
very important partnership between
academia industry and in the government
our first speaker this afternoon is very
well known to any of you who are
interested in the problems of drawing
into the next century women and people
from underrepresented groups who would
be the leaders of the scientific
revolutions of the 21st century along
with the more traditional sources of
students that we've been able to inspire
for us for well over a century in our
great research universities
Sheila Tobias has a distinguished career
as a scientist and as a writer her
recent book science as a career
perceptions in reality is the third in a
series of books that she's written for
the Research Corporation as part of a
long-term research and writing
assignment in an area called neglected
issues in science education the first to
which I commend to you if you have not
read them the first which are they're
not dumb they're different Stocking the
second tier and revitalizing
undergraduate science why some things
work and most don't both of these issues
stalking the second tier and why some
things work and some don't continue to
vex us as we move into the future she's
been a college lecturer and
administrator at City College of New
York
Cornell Wesleyan and many other
distinguished institutions around the
country she was educated in history and
literature at a famous institution here
in the in the city of Cambridge Harvard
Radcliffe
she's Phi Beta Kappa and hold a man
holds a master's degree in European
history and politics from Columbia and
two honorary doctorates in Humane
Letters and one in education I followed
Sheila's work for many years and I think
it will be a real pleasure for us to
hear from her first this afternoon
Sheila I've decided to stand in the
middle and use this portable microphone
is it on and the transparencies one of
the things that happens when you
change cultures which I've done in my
career begun to work in with scientists
not in science is that you discover
other means of communication I become
very attached to transparencies more
obviously than the rest of you so I'm
gonna stand right here and use my
transparencies let me begin by noticing
what was for me a serious missing issue
at this meeting as I would formulate it
it's the question of how to maintain the
attachment of young scientists to
science who do not have jobs in science
who are unemployed or underemployed and
if you talk to them they have no
certainty that they will ever be
employed in science
I was surprised there was nothing
mentioned of the jobs problem which is
by now real and undeniable and I just
wanted to make sure that I mentioned it
if no one else did I think high on the
priority list of the people going around
the country to have these hearings
should be of the need to figure out ways
to increase demand for science trained
professionals for me as an educator
education and I'm going to make that
case today is one means actually of
simulating demand to anticipate my
remarks if we can differently educate
different kinds of students for
different kinds of work in science we
can actually increase the demand for
science trained professionals but it
would be remiss of me to let you believe
that education is is by itself going to
do the job I think as a nation we have
an obligation to find ways of continuing
to supply students to government and
industry and universities we also have
an obligation to continue to create a
demand for them so they can have
reasonable lives and that's really why I
am going to and the context in which I'm
going to present my argument today you
may wonder why and and the marsinah
spoke which I take as a flattery that I
I'm not a scientist and you might wonder
why the one person on your program who's
not a scientist was the one person asked
to talk with you open your discussion
about undergraduate education in science
I think the reason is that most of those
scientists and mathematicians and
engineers who are engaged now in
educational reform at the undergraduate
level
they're legion something they're very
dedicated most of them are dealing
pretty exclusively within classroom
issues issues of pedagogy issues of
curriculum issues of appropriate
technology for teaching and learning
unlike them because my background is
social science I've been dealing with
what social scientists call the deep
structures of undergraduate education
not the means by which some immediately
obvious problem can be solved by an
improved technology or curriculum my
questions have been these deep
structures have been questions like this
looking at whom we recruit to science
and what we expect them to do with the
science they learn in college that to me
is not beyond conversation that's
something we should be discussing whom
do we recruit to science in college what
do we tell them we expect them to do
with their science in college what is
the culture of the classroom in science
how does that culture
apart from intelligence or talent serve
to discourage other kinds of students
from participating in science what are
the assumptions that are made by science
faculty about teaching and learning and
how are those assumptions
operationalized in the classroom and
when have they last examine those
assumptions that they make about who can
learn science and how people demonstrate
ability learn science and who can't oh
how are we to teach vertical subjects
these are real intractable problems how
can you talk about innovative means of
teaching subjects that are highly
vertical in their structure how can you
talk about different topical sequences
when as you know better than I and
social science there is a comfortable
nesting of concept within concept and
that is unique to science and above all
and I want to put a kind of handmade
transparency here for you to look at as
I mentioned this above all how do we
deal with the ideology of recruitment
and advancement in science which is
based on my observations for support
poles which are extremely difficult to
get
scientist to acknowledge and and to
break away from the elitism that is to
say only the very best can do science
people with a very special quality of
mind can do science that if you're doing
very well in political science or at
literature it may not bear at all on
your capacity to do science
something I call predestiny rien ism a
notion that if your talent for science
is there at all it's going to show up
early if at all and if you haven't shown
that interest that talent that
inclination by age 15 or 10 or eight
there's really no point teaching you
there's really no point are we winning
you to the subject because it starts
early if at all the notion that science
is a calling so that the undergraduate
with multiple interests and multiple
talents who's not yet sure if he or he
wants to go to law school or maybe
medicine or maybe geology or maybe
literature is considered not a serious
student of science because serious
students of science are quite
single-minded with some exceptions but
to reveal to your science instructor
that you're wavering between science and
some other subjects is to be taken less
seriously and altogether what we in
social science call a solid sysm meaning
that there's a tendency on the part of
instructors of undergraduates to
extrapolate back from their own
experience to see some students as
younger versions of themselves exciting
to teach exciting to open these doors to
and others as not interesting at all and
so underlying the you know whether or
not we change a curriculum or a change a
pedagogy it seems to me if we don't
change some of these ideas about who can
do science when that ability to do
science first manifests itself and then
how we deal with students who perhaps
are a little different I don't think
we're gonna make much progress as
regards inclusiveness in the course of
my research I've had to formulate some
new questions and invent some new
methodologies to get at new truths for
example I asked the question some years
ago what would happen if we enrolled
extremely able learners from fields
other than science in traditional
introductory physical science courses
physics
and chemistry at college what would it
be like if they were in every way equal
or potentially equal to their
instructors in intelligence an ability
to focus in self-discipline in in verbal
fluency only different in one variable
that they were new to the field what
could we learn about how science is
packaged how it appears to otherwise
extremely intelligent students the
reason I formulated the question that
way is it's very hard for teachers
teaching undergraduates to get the kind
of feedback from them that they take
seriously because after all the
undergraduates are very young they can't
articulate exactly what their problems
are and they do have problems that good
learners don't have and from that
research which Marcis recommended to you
the book was called they're not dumb
they're different emerge what I call a
tear analysis of the typical college
introductory course in in physical
science and I'll talk about the
introductory course a couple of times
today as well as the major in essence
that when the professor looks out at a
sea of faces in early September of a new
year in an intro physics or chemistry
course and those are the two fields I've
studied he or she looks out and sees
consciously or not a small group of
students who remind him or her of
themselves as young younger learners who
are exciting to teach who are I call
them the first-year students who in fact
I go so far as to say probably would
teach themselves almost doesn't matter
what curriculum what pedagogy they are
dedicated to becoming scientists or to
learning science at a fast clip and then
everybody else is lumped together again
perhaps not consciously by the professor
as them as a group of very different
students whose needs whose reasons for
being there are some how mysterious
whose response the material is
unfamiliar who are very hard to teach
and whose learning styles are difficult
to understand and what I tried to do in
this first research about undergraduate
science teaching and learning was to
offer to the science community a
slightly warmer for a refined way of
thinking about the them in that in that
surface namely that it consists of a
number of different kinds of students
not to do
that there's a first year where younger
versions of themselves really easy and a
joy to teach but that among those who
are unfamiliar are gradations of
difference that are as different one
from another as they are from the first
year and that the most interesting group
within that and I'll come back to them
several times today as regards demand is
the second tier and the second tier of
students I have defined operationally as
otherwise extremely able young people
who are going far in their lives by
means of other disciplines and whose
alienation from science through that
first negative experience comes back and
haunts the science community they become
the journalists and the editors they
become elected or not so elected
officials they become spokespeople Lori
I didn't want to say it but if you
insist many of them become lawyers they
are out there and they have bring with
them from the limited experience they
have in science three lessons that are
not reversed one that they're not very
good at it you let them know that quick
to that they don't like it very much and
three and this is a natural self defense
of a bruised ego that it's probably not
very important and and off they go into
the world so the cheer analysis was
perceived by by me and by others as very
significant it became obvious to me that
we needed to look not just as where
things were not going well but also it
at who does the job well and I did
another study called their of revitalize
the undergraduate science in which I
looked at a number of cases where
science was being taught successfully
and my definition of successful was high
recruitment high retention high morale
and in these places I found and it is
not perhaps central to all of your
interest but I already put it any way
that in most places it wasn't the
gimmicky curriculum it wasn't the brand
new pedagogy however well-defined these
are these days it was really a quality
of attention to students needs a set of
expectations that were realistic in some
of the fancier schools students would
say that this
course did not play to my strengths in
these places where science was more
popular and where it was doing a very
very good job a variety of strengths
would generate a successful and and
winning experience in science for the
student and so we learn from that
but the third study Marci remembered
also for Research Corporation which
produces these books and distributes
them at almost no cost is a study of
science as a career and I want you to
consider as I go through these remarks
the role that science education at the
undergraduate level could play in
promoting science more generally among
the public we've talked some about that
today they need to package it better to
sell it better to convey to the public
what it needs to know and I've heard the
term science literacy used loosely as if
there we were there was a binary
distribution of people those who are
extremely well educated in science and
those who own them almost know nothing
and I want to raise the possibility with
you that there's a population out there
of people whom we could educate as
undergraduates in science for different
purposes who could serve us very well in
promoting science what we're challenging
in the book that we're writing right now
is the common view that demand creates
supply that we have to wait passively
for demand for science trained
professionals to make itself felt and
then in response supply will be
generated we're trying to make the case
that a we can stimulate demand by
restructuring supply and the argument
goes like this if we were to target some
different populations let me find my
next one of undergraduates now not just
for the first course but actually
through the major if for example we
could get this second tier to stay in
science longer to do more science and
I'm not talking here about phd's by any
means but at least through the major or
through a substantial chunk of science
in combination with other majors we
could I think by itself by increasing
the numbers of students who are
suing science at the undergraduate level
improve the quality and the numbers of
people teaching high school I mean
that's obvious
even more importantly I think is to
increase the mix of people practicing a
wide range of support activities for
science and before you perhaps dismiss
the notion that there are a wide range
of support activities for science let me
throw on the transparency board a list
of tasks for science that Linda Wilson
who's president of Radcliffe and herself
a chemist has come up with just for you
to contemplate as I make the case that
among the tasks for science are all of
these they're 10 there you can read at
your leisure of which discovery of
knowledge of new knowledge which we
heard much about today is one and an
extremely important one and one for whom
I would not venture to challenge you
only a few extremely talented people are
qualified or qualifiable but forgotten
very often in the education agenda at
the undergraduate level is that there
are many other tasks in science for
science that will support science to
which other kinds of students might be
directed whose interest in science is
real whose capacity for learning science
is substantial but who are not
necessarily going to a PhD or going to
become a principal investigator or going
to do a bench research for most of their
lives and so when we talk about
increasing the mix of people who pursue
science at the undergraduate level it
shouldn't be misunderstood that we're
going to flood the graduate schools and
the PhD programs with all of these
especially in a time of job shortage but
rather that we could create from these
populations a group of people who could
do different kinds of jobs and science
which in the aggregate together would
promote Science in the community they
could become a support system for
science and the third of value in
looking to educate the second tier
so-called or or students like them is
that it could print it could provide a
jumpstart in demand first
ion's trained professionals in other
fields in other words there are two
specific target populations that I think
we are missing in our recruitment of
undergraduates to the science major one
of them is the the science the student
who likes science very much would enjoy
doing science might even do it through
the master's degree in order to
participate in science in a different
way than at the bench
the second population that I think we've
ignored out of the elitism or perhaps
the salep sysm you can choose your cause
is the group of students who are on
their way to other professions quite
determined to be in law or in business
or in journalism or in government but
for whom the science training at the
undergraduate level could give them a
base from which they could become good
problem solvers to be sure but a base
from which they could bring a pro
science orientation to whatever realms
in in which they operated later bring
that science orientation to insurance or
to banking or to any of these others and
I think those two populations might have
a nice overlap I don't want to demarcate
any more than you have demarcated in the
past but I think that at an effort a
real campaign to attract such students
to the science major possibly altered in
some ways would be very useful and let
me move now in the interest of time to
some of those models in the research we
did for this book we found a number of
programs that are limping along they
don't have as much support nationally as
as they might and let me just see if I
can here we are and let me just go
through some examples of these some of
the majors that will attract these two
different target populations are going
to look a little different from some of
the majors that have really been
designed to move students efficiently
and rapidly through the undergraduate
program so that they can move on to
graduate school
in science clearly and because there's
been no central national interest in
these populations a number of schools
have had to be inventive on their own
bootstrap their way into some some of
these imaginative programs and I've just
put them into some categories for the
sake of walking you briefly through them
and if you want much more information
I'd be glad to tell you where these are
taking place one route is the enhanced
traditional a traditional major in the
physical sciences that is enhanced or
enriched with something else and often
it is the other else is another science
it has always struck me as an outsider's
remarkable how little chemistry a
physics major has to learn or knows even
by the time he or she finishes or the
absence of biology as a as in a rigorous
way from the the straight chemistry
majors career line or of course again
from physics and so in these instances
they haven't gone all the way to
modifying the major and challenging that
but they're trying to offer some
enrichment in a in a lateral direction
in a sideways direction for their
undergraduate majors others have taken
the step the next step and recommended
or created closely-knit
strong minors that is to say the student
doesn't have the freedom to choose any
minor but a particular mindset
such that the student with the strong
major and strong minors having an
integrated cohered program and among
those are chemistry with business in a
number of places physics with business
where the business courses are not the
ordinary business courses because they
might be not as useful and may be too
elementary but courses in legal issues
of regulation would be a business course
that the physics major would be
emboldened to take as part of this dual
major a strong minor the next away from
traditional would be the dual major
actually two majors where some amount of
the science is lopped off has to be
there's a limited amount of time credits
that could be yet gotten others goes so
farther they are
really interdisciplinary for you too
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill has our material science programs
people can take in the biological line
or in the in the chemical line or as an
engineering major my typing leaves
something to be desired applied science
that was supposed to read and we are
informed by Verna Wolfe who is at Yale
and who wrote an article in physics
today recently that when he did a survey
of what physics majors take in addition
to their major he found to his shock
that only 2% even take computer science
courses fewer than 1% take chemistry
courses and they are not many of them
involved in Applied Science that's going
a little farther afield but it is being
considered by a number of places are
there are places where science and
technology are formally integrated in
non engineering programs and then both
to my heart are places where a core
sequence of some science is being
offered or sold to social science majors
those people who are moving to
government who will be in regulation so
they have something equivalent to what
the pre-medical student might have or
maybe even ideally equivalent to at the
MIT undergraduate would have who would
major here in social science or core and
I put in parentheses coherent science
sequence for business and economics
majors so you can see where where I'm
going with this it seems to me that we
are depriving a group of extremely able
if differently configured undergraduates
of an opportunity to learn science
sequentially and learn a lot of it this
is not physics for poets at the same
time we're depriving ourselves
yourselves as a science community of the
support and the promotion and the
commitment to science that such a
population would have if treated
seriously and if educated at the
undergraduate level and with that
challenge and an invitation to read this
book which has as a chapter from which
this comes chapter called restructuring
supply let me turn to yes John Armstrong
who's my counterpart for graduate
education thank you
I think actually our next speaker is Jim
Vincent who joined Biogen as its
chairman and CEO in 1985 as you know bio
chants one of the leading front
biopharmaceutical companies in the world
he formerly served as president of
allied health and scientific products
which is a subsidiary of allied signal
he's a member of the board of the
biotechnology industry organization
boards of trustees of both Duke in the
University of Pennsylvania he was
selected by industry week I was
interested to notice as one of the top
15 industrial CEOs in America in 1990
and New England business magazine named
him business Person of the Year he did
he received his own bachelor science
degree in mechanical engineering from
Duke and a Master of Business
Administration from Wharton graduate
Business School at the University of
Pennsylvania so he is already one of
these well integrated individuals that
is taking a science background and a
business background to very high to very
great heights indeed and we'll be happy
to hear what you can what perspective
you can give us this afternoon Jim
thanks Thank You Marcy I think it was
Yogi Berra as well who when I was young
and playing football in my younger days
said that see students rule the world so
I didn't worry much about that stuff
even though I was headed for a business
career but now that I have heard John
matang today talk about the PhDs and
professors taking over and also you see
the Republican Party how their staffing
the new the new era and the new people
and the professors and PhDs are taking
over I think I better rethink that
paradigm I was interested also in
Sheila's remarks I learned something
today which I'm going to tell you that
I'm going to engage in some solace isms
today
and also I learned something that I
think my kids in there who are in their
20s are going to really appreciate that
instead of having to hear about when I
was a boy and I walked up and down those
cobblestone hills both ways to that
one-room schoolhouse I can now say well
I'm gonna have a solid season for you
now as we go into whatever conversation
that relates to something like that when
Chuck wrote to me I was quite shocked
and taken aback Chuck vest in in giving
me my remit wanting me to comment on
what changes are needed in undergraduate
science education to better prepare
students in the future for future needs
of the biotech industry and industry in
general and realizing that the last time
I really visited science on an academic
basis was when I left Duke University
with my mechanical engineering degree in
hand in 1961 I'm going to do that but
it's going to be brief quite frankly
because I think most of this from the
perspective that I bring to it in
industry in these last 30 years in the
electronics business the first half of
it in in in semiconductors and in
biotechnology went from a spark chaser
to a bug man in biology in the last half
of it has been good has been good news
so I don't have a lot of things really
to delve into there from the viewpoint
of the customer if you will in industry
then I'd like to switch though to more a
few comments about concerns and threats
I see at the institutional level which
if not dealt with successfully will
impact undergraduate education just as
it will impact everything else that that
goes on in the institution and in that
although I want to comment a little bit
about some of this government discussion
that's been going on I also want to jump
to some other subjects that don't relate
to how government's going to impact the
lives of of these institutions again let
me come back and say I mean I I think
that the the educational institutions of
this country at the university level
that are doing the undergraduate
training of our students in science and
tech
are creating in the main of course
there's differences in gradations but in
the main product and students that meet
the needs that we have in the main I
think also you are winning the global
competitive battle in in market standing
and reputation I mean from it if you
think of this in industry terms the way
we would in big or small companies I
mean an end most in any industry would
kill to be in the position that higher
education is in this country at both the
undergraduate level and the graduate
level in terms of the quality of what
you're producing and the demand that you
have and and the worldwide demand that
you have you could probably if you
opened your doors a large percentage of
the institutions of this country could
fill their fill their classes with
students from totally outside the United
States that's quite a testimony when you
think on a relative basis of competitive
setting I mean these folks have been at
it some of them a lot longer than we
have in this country in Europe and other
parts of the world in China and Japan I
would also comment that in my experience
again crossing over from electronics in
my days with Texas Instruments when I
spent almost 10 years outside the United
States building businesses in Europe for
them and then going and living in Tokyo
and building businesses in the Far East
from Japan starting the first the first
non-japanese semiconductor wholly owned
business in Japan to take on the
Japanese in their home country down
through Taiwan Singapore Malaysia and so
forth and in the process of doing that
and since then as well in the healthcare
industry hiring students undergraduate
science and technology students graduate
into many of these different settings
that I have commented and continued to
comment for years that I think that we
in this country as compared to our
counterparts in Europe in Japan and
other parts of the world are better
preparing students at least to come into
industry from the point of view of the
kinds of industries with very rapid
change etc
I've been involved with what do I mean
by that I mean it most in the breadth
and diversity of the problem-solving
skills that that the young students are
prepared to deal with the they may
contain as compared for example to their
Japanese or European counterpart they
may contain at least if I go back 10 or
15 years I'm not as current on this
point today they may they may they may
have in their memory banks less rote
detail that they can use instantaneously
in a subspecialty of a subject than
their American counterparts but in the
main I found them to be a more adaptable
and more nimble in climbing the new
learning curves that classically have to
have to be dealt with in a very
environment of very high rates of change
and that I've lived in also I think
you're in a healthy situation from the
point of view of the markets for your
graduates are very strong I hear
complaints I hear concerns just like I
hear at for example in my pen experience
at the Wharton School for the Graduate
MBAs they wring their hands a lot these
last several years about how oh my god
it's so much more difficult to get a job
at someone when you really scratch on it
and look at it most of them in that
setting are still winding up with two
and three jobs for person what they're
finding is and I think this is a lot of
this translation of greater difficulty
is that the market is restructuring I
mean it is a realistic fact that fortune
500 world has been shrinking in
employment for 15 years I mean we read
about this this is true this is true and
all of the growth in in the economy in
terms of new jobs has come in the
entrepreneurial economy so that changes
the challenge that both our
undergraduate students have be it
science or whatever and our graduate
students they have to look different
places they have to be taught to think
differently about how they go to job
search it's not like when I came out and
you know 87 company show up and the big
decision was which seven or eight do I
want to interview with and what
competitive system do you designed to
divide up you know who they can talk to
that's a changing and I assume that's
also true here it at MIT and I would
suggest that that's going to get more so
so teaching them how to think
differently about how to go about a job
search and where the jobs are
you know the Willie Sutton approach you
know where is the new money don't go to
parking meters go you know where is the
money where are the banks it's different
places different techniques and I think
that explains a lot of of the what is
perceived as more difficult less demand
and so forth and then of course you have
this concern that I hear I hear at some
of the other schools I'm associated with
I'm sure you have it here as well the
hand wringing of the of the faculty I'm
from time to time is oh my god here
comes the these sharks from Wall Street
stealing our science students that we
have nurtured so so you know assiduously
and carefully and it's going to derail
their entire what's this going to do it
they gonna take all of them are gonna
have no more engineers and no more
science majors and it's kind of I would
suggest to you I wouldn't gee I think I
think it's a testimony a couple things
number one is you're you're you're
developing problem solvers that are
flexible that are needed and I would
just say the second thing is markets
have a way of working those things out
even though Sheila wanted to react
before the market I would suggest
markets will deal with that it'll either
either you get saturated on the non
scientific endeavor side or those those
are those areas that need more
scientists well will will balance out in
terms of the of how they adjusted the
man and the price of labor in that sense
so I just conclude in terms of where
we're at today on undergraduate science
training that we should feel proud about
very proud about this track record both
domestically and on a global basis and
that we should we should be thinking
about how do we do more of the same it
doesn't mean we can't improve of course
but not get complacent as any success
story that can be the seeds of disaster
because there's no question no question
that and I won't have anything new and
fundamental here but the threats on the
horizon to the institutions that if not
dealt with skillfully could impact the
undergraduate as well as graduate
educational experience I think
har-har obvi I mean many of them are
obvious and and and many of them are
quite complex and it's not
straightforward to figure out how to
deal with them so let's go on and point
at try to let me try to highlight a
couple of those and we'll put this in
the category of maybe the bad news okay
no question I guess sitting here I sat
here and heard all of the comments today
which I found most informative a lot of
it by I must add for you that it's some
of it is like inside the beltway and
insider baseball kind of stuff so that
if I if I react to some of this in a way
that doesn't sound like I'm connecting
very well I'm probably not some of this
I'm hearing some of these words I'm
hearing you know for the first time
lingo and some of the subtleties and
nuances you talk about between the
government and everything else I am I'm
straining to connect with so if I miss
if I miss here you know just give me cut
me a little slack if I'm off base and
correct me and you can get me later in
the questioning
first and foremost clearly the economic
playing field is changing of course it
is it's changing in a couple of very
significant ways we've heard number of
hours today about how it's changing on
the government funding level and that's
the subject the number one subject as I
go travel in the country and run into
academics today that is the subject that
everybody wants to talk about I would
suggest you it's also changing in in
another very significant way as the days
of double-digit tuition increases have
got to come to an end and they they're
coming to an end quickly I would
forecast for you and the days of when
you sit down with University budgets and
face the issue of how are we going to
discipline the increase in expenditures
and you walk up to that cliff and then
you back away and say oh I can't do that
I can't cut this let's just increase the
student body some more and dodge that
bullet
for another year I suggest those days
are gonna have to come to an end as well
as a continuing source of revenue now
let me first of all come to the external
I'll call the external part of that the
out out looking
what can we you know if I were sitting
here and I were in Chuck's shoes I mean
what or the faculty what can we do about
this the external part and specifically
as it relates to government now and then
come back for a minute to looking inward
what can we do institutional maybe some
thoughts and ideas there seems to me
that that and the external one as it
relates to the federal government state
I guess a little bit mostly federal in
this case there's there's the approach
that's the heat and there's the approach
that's the light there's there's two
potential parts to this I would call the
heat part is the classical one of the
pie is shrinking oh my god and the way
to respond to it is we've got to sell
more we've got to promote more we've got
the field more lobbyists or whatever we
do however we influence that equation
down there inside the beltway what we
have to do is step up the pressure so we
get a bigger piece in a zero-sum game of
the pie for us that's the heat part
that's been the classical way most of
these things have been dealt with
unfortunately in Washington for too many
years in my opinion and I get fed up
with it in terms of the industrial
issues that I deal with the health care
having been involved in spending some
very serious personal time in the health
care debate in the last year and a half
I got it right up to here with that's
you know what it was about not as what's
best for the country what's good public
policy I hear that less and less and
less in Washington over the past 10 or
15 years the light part is the one that
says if we think about it I think there
is maybe a better shot today than at
least in in in my relevant political
observing life in the last 15 or 20
years a better shot today that that we
can create a new paradigm on a number of
fronts here with these with these
Teutonic play
changes that seem to be may be occurring
maybe they are that's significant and I
do believe that we have we do have some
people down there that on the Congress
side for a change that really are pretty
good thinkers they are professors they
are academics
well it's certainly on the Republican
side this is a whole new experience
compared to what it was 25 years ago I
believe many of them really are
interested in ideas in experimentation
and we see things happening now that
looks like it at least a greater chance
again than I've seen for a long time
that we will take seriously getting the
budget balanced and get an amendment to
to help bring pressure to that getting a
line-item veto for the president my god
I think that would be wonderful so we
could hold that person accountable for a
change so I write a lot of these things
that are being talked about whether it's
the contract with america or whether
what follows that on the Democratic side
I don't think this is all Republican and
I think you see these votes in that both
sides House and Senate you see a new
coalition's forming here that are both
Democrat and Republican so the point of
this is this that you know again back to
Yogi Berra I think he said if you when
you come don't always remember when you
come to a fork in the road take it you
know and so I would suggest this that in
addition to going and thinking about the
old ways of approaching this of how can
we make sure we get our maximize our
piece of that pie in the zero-sum game
etc etc I would encourage you and it's
not just for the academic and
educational establishment I think it's
for other establishments in this country
to put some serious energy into thinking
about the light part of put yourself in
the position of maybe some of these
leaders and leaders to be in the future
are in a position of wanting to do some
change here with the with the idea of
what is best public policy for this
country or in put themselves in the role
of a CEO of a corporation where that's
what you're trying to optimize all of
this and what is best for employees
customers shareholders suppliers in your
your in the role of optimizing and
last thing you need when you get into
heavy-duty water-carrying and when
you've got problems on your hands and
you've got to deal with changing your
mission you've got to deal with
downsizing it the last thing you need is
every part of your organization coming
at you from the angle that just says you
know take care of that other person over
there not me
you know I deserve more you can't cut me
take that you can't you never solve
anything that way fairly obvious but but
if the people are serious down there
about trying to change that they're
going to need some of that kind of help
because they sure as hell are not going
to have all the ideas in the world I
would also just offer a few I'll jump
around here for just a little bit
clearly I think a relevant question is
what should be the size of this
establishment going for we got a set of
different set of needs now that again
the Cold War is over the the academic
establishment has been in the business
of being what I call the line research
organization for the government for
quite a number of years for defense for
a time nuclear policy and so that's over
largely over that alone would indicate
there's got to be a major rethink of
what is that you know what is the right
size going forward of the the global
resource we're putting into this I found
it unbelievable to hear this morning the
comment that here we are worried about
some serious resource issues across the
board and you have the Gallivan
Commission saying not only don't you
need a four hundred million dollar
increase in the in the do-e laboratories
you can run on a hell of a lot less but
their budget comes forward I'm four
hundred million dollar increase and then
incredible I mean isn't that incredible
that's that's that mentality of you
never you never cut or destroy anything
as a model
let me now jump and comment on something
that's received a lot of discussion
here's where I get a little lost
sometimes in some of the inside baseball
as I referring to this Science and
Technology fundamental research and what
should the government be doing and
funding and whatnot and so forth from
the perspective where I said I'll tell
you I think we have a model going in
this country that I haven't seen a
better one that's
played out in the last 20 years and it's
the NIH model I think it's a model from
the point of view of where do you stop
with government funding you stop at the
scientific threshold there and and and
and then it's a model in the sense of
how you you pass the baton to private
industry and and it's a model in the
sense of people talk about how
short-term Wall Street is and so on it's
on do you realize that that in this case
in the biotechnology industry Wall
Street private sources have invested
more than 10 billion of new money in the
last dozen years 10 billion ok to take
this technology forward that is in turn
created 250 public firms that are listed
on the stock exchange
another 3 or 400 firms only five of us
are profitable today on a consistent
basis the rest of the of the 4 or 500
firms are using cash at the rate of 200
million dollars a month that is being
financed largely by private sources at
this point in time gee I think that's
some long-term thinking I think that's
evidence that the market can react to
and support things that have time
horizons that are longer than just a
year to in advance it's been gone on
since the late 70s and there's only four
or five of us they say that are
profitable companies for God's sake
everybody else lose money and it still
be now is there going to be a
consolidation yep it's beginning now but
nobody would have forecasting you've
gotten this kind of support for that
long so I think again the NIH model I
think has worked well from the point of
view of ICI I think it works because you
we have a scientific in the
infrastructure in this country that can
work with government at the science
level to establish excellence and that
works well and you you all do that very
very well it's when you have to then
have people who have multidisciplinary
skills making calls about how do we go
forward from here when you gotta have
different disciplines in addition to
science and you gotta have people who
have the invisible hand of Adam Smith on
their shoulder and so that it becomes a
rational process is not a political
process political process
one of the great fails one of the great
advantages capitalist system is it's one
of the only systems where things get
stopped once it gets in a political
system nothing gets stopped I mean we
all hear these fantastic stories about
all these agencies we have that go back
that were designed for things 100 years
ago and they're still hanging around
same thing happens when you get the
government funding things when it gets
applied I you know I'm gonna get in
trouble here using these words but once
you get out of that that ability of our
system to make decisions on a scientific
excellent bait excellence basis and you
need multidisciplinary I mean look at
the examples of Japan I've been there oh
my god I remember the days when I was
over there all we used to hear about
Japan we were gonna compete with them in
computer disseminators they're planning
this thing boy they were to they were
planning this from Tokyo how they were
gonna they're gonna take over computers
in the world they messed it up they went
with the IBM model too long look at the
HDTV TV story how many times do we hear
they don't wipe us out in
high-definition television
technological gear shift they're sitting
out there in a cold in left field look
at the French model over the years where
they tried to centrally plan that stuff
doesn't work so the science model the
NIH model I think works just great and
also let's not lose the gains we've made
we are the envy of the world when you
talk to both academics and Industrial
folks in Europe and Japan of the
advances we've made in the last 15 year
10 years especially in the 80s in this
country of how we're able to move
Science and Technology science from from
the universities and the government labs
into the private sector they haven't
they can't touch us on that they don't
have the trust levels they don't have
the communication levels they have all
other kinds of barriers they can't touch
us on doing that and so let's not lose
that also as we as we go about working
with us moving on very quickly internal
the attorney to the internal what is
this funding and that thing do as far as
if you're sitting and running one of
these institutions what what should
thoughts some of the thoughts come to
mind in business terms I would say this
looks like to me the way we describe it
is your largest customers getting
smaller
in an economic sense government and your
price is too high tuition and you know
it's not dissimilar to what many
industries have faced in the last 15
years the the John's comments on the
automotive industry look at that I mean
in addition to what he pointed out I
think again competition and costs being
totally outlined and quality getting out
of line and finally the lights went on
and the industry started to move and now
arguably Ford is the lowest cost
producer as I read it based on studies
here at MIT maybe not
Toyota yet but any rate may be getting
to the point of being lowest cost
producer in the world quality levels are
changing I mean you go through the steel
industry etc etc these things happen and
you've got to sharpen the focus on the
mission of the institution maybe what
it's been built to be over the past 10
or 15 or 20 years that the mission
should be modified at this point in time
maybe it doesn't have to be the same to
have the contribution and the excellence
going forward that it has had this one
or others for the last decades in the
past most certainly I would suggest it's
going to stress leadership of the
institutions of our universities like
they've never been stressed before
because when you go through this very
hard choices have to be made and that's
where leadership gets gets stressed
normally enormous ly different couple of
subjects I'll just hit quickly and then
sit down concern the balance between
teaching and research in our in our
undergraduate and graduate but
especially our undergraduate programs is
a concern I have as I interacted
different institutions it still seems to
me that the reason the most compelling
reason we have these these these these
places is for the students and I I think
our reward system and our career try out
our processes that we set up that lead
to career advancement and tenure are out
of balance in terms of of motivating
teaching versus research and most
interesting what
I find in a number of institutions not
this one but others that I interact with
is we don't even have the metrics and
most of our institutions some very good
ones to even know where we stand on
teaching quality with high quality
real-time dynamic data I would give you
odds that of our top best 10 best
graduate business schools of this
country that a majority of those schools
do not have the metrics to adequately
and with high accuracy measure their
teaching performance in the schools you
know what if if we ever had that issue
exists in business us graduates of those
schools it would be heresy something as
important as teaching quality that we
wouldn't have the metrics in place to
measure that that would be like saying
we don't do any market research on our
most important product or customers or
something and you know we just in
today's world of business technology
would be it would be absolute heresy so
that's where I'd start
I'd say do we have the metrics to know
where we released and are they anonymous
and not can't be influenced by teachers
coming from the students are they real
time are they dynamic this is not rocket
science in today's world how you do this
this is straightforward stuff and I
would say if you don't measure it you're
not terribly concerned about it and if
you don't measure it well okay K through
12 education
oh my glory talk about talk about an
issue that can impact our is impacting
undergraduate education an issue crying
for re-engineering to use that over word
use term how long are we going to sit
here and let politicians convince us
that the answer is just pour more money
in it just keep increasing the real
money thrown at the problem and it's
going to solve it while results continue
to plummet and we have we have models in
our environment the benchmark look at
the parochial schools right here in
Boston down in New York City they
outperform the public schools by a
country mile but yet we let these forces
that were referred to or earlier unions
plus other stand in the way intimidate
people about even experimentation that
ought to be going on a major role
aggressive role I think can be played by
institutions of this ilk and and in
this quality in not a coming of the
ideas but really ringing the alarm bells
if let's get on with this let's get this
nonsense behind us and the final point
is this issue of diversity I just think
it's very very important as we try to
balance all of these pressures that we
remember that the date we came with to
this party that created this phenomenal
success in this country is one of a
meritocracy and one that is about
providing equal opportunities not equal
outcomes and I think we ought to stay
with that date or we're gonna mess up on
both fronts we're gonna mess up on the
social engineering side and we're gonna
mess up on the quality of education side
we're not going to do either one of them
well thank you very much thank you Jim
we're going to I think it would be very
useful and Mark and I were sitting here
chatting for a second if we could
integrate the whole discussion about
education including the undergraduate
and the graduate education so if the two
speakers to follow don't mind we'll go
forward and then we'll have a roundtable
discussion at the end so our next
speaker is dr. Ellen Brownlee well known
to all of those in this room I'm sure is
one of the world's leading nuclear
physicists his laboratories graduated
many leaders in experimental physics and
his scientific reputation is very well
known and very well recognized both by
the award of the National Medal of
Science and his election to the National
Academy of Sciences but in particular of
course he was Jack Givens his
predecessor immediate predecessor as the
assistant for science and technology to
the President of the United States and
director of the Office of Science and
Technology Policy Sochi so he brings to
us not only his new perspective as Dean
of engineering at Yale and the
perspective that that he brings with
that to graduate education but also his
recent perspective on the politics of
Washington and the changing environment
in which both undergraduate and graduate
education will be out
meaning for the foreseeable future so
Alan if you'll take the podium Thank You
Marcy I don't think I need to emphasize
to anyone in this room that we have what
could be described as a paradoxical
situation in education there's a general
agreement that we have the finest
graduate education anywhere in the world
because we're the only nation the only
developed nation that doesn't have some
sort of centralized standards for what
constitutes a college education
we have peaks of excellence that are way
beyond world standards like this one
here at MIT and we also have vast swamps
of mediocrity that defy description but
if we average the whole thing we are
probably competitive with the rest of
the world it's at the pre-college level
where things really go to hell and we've
heard something of this I funded a major
attempt to improve the ETS international
comparative examinations in 92 and when
they were applied to a universe of 22
nations not to anyone's great surprise
we fared worse than in any previous test
we were number 21 in the universe of 22
nations just behind Slovenia and just
ahead of Jordan and so we have problems
but my task this afternoon as I
understand it as Chuck FASST pointed out
to me although I'm not gonna do exactly
what he said I never do they the
I'm going to talk about graduate
education and I want to talk about it in
at least at the beginning and rather
general terms and I want to focus on
problems and unless anyone really gets
too discouraged let me Telegraph my
conclusion that I am fundamentally an
optimist always have been and remain one
but we do have some serious problems let
me just touch on a few of them one of
the most serious is the fact that
universities and particularly the
research universities about somewhere
between 150 and 175 of the 3,000
colleges and universities in this
country have a very serious problem in
that we have lost very quickly over a
very short period the trust and respect
that we had unquestionably for decades
after World War two and we've lost it
because of a very small number of
incidences all of you know about them
that have been very highly publicized
hype beyond all belief but the fact
remains that we have lost the trust and
respect of the Congress and of the
public and one of our major goals one of
our major
absolute requirements in the future is
to work as hard as we can to
re-establish and regain that trust in
that respect because without that we are
going to have grave difficulties in
almost every activity in which we engage
at the university end of the equation I
find a year ago little more than a year
ago now I had the opportunity to visit a
great many of these research intensive
universities and there's an overwhelming
decrease in the level of confidence
of the students of the faculty everyone
everyone's worried they're worried about
whether there's going to be adequate
support for research activities they're
worried about whether there are going to
be adequate career opportunities for the
students and indeed a great many people
are fundamentally worried about the
future of our entire society and they
have some not unreasonable bases before
those worries but I think that one of
the most serious questions that we have
to address is the fact that over the
past decades we have allowed the career
horizons of our graduate students to
shrink and in fact a great many graduate
students today feel that they achieve
first-class citizenship only by cloning
their professors career laboratory
lifestyle you name it as quickly as
possible on this trip that I mentioned
earlier I was able to predict after I'd
visited a relatively small number of
institutions that the more prestigious
the institution the more certain it was
that sometime during the day of our
meeting somebody was going to say
essentially verbatim if my grant doesn't
come through I may have to consider
industry as if this was some exquisite
form of prostitution there is a very low
survival potential in this sort of thing
and it's something that clearly is I
think the fault of the faculty not the
students now I'll come back to that in
just a moment we tend to take our
leadership in higher education I think a
little too much for granted we are
focused as we must be on what's
happening at pre-college what's
happening at the undergraduate level
and there's a great tendency just to
assume that things will go on as in the
past that in the graduate schools of the
nation we will continue to set world
standards and all will be reasonably
well that however I think is unrealistic
and certainly not the way the future
seems to look both from my days in
Washington and now back at a major
university I think we have to bear in
mind that in December of 92 the
President's Council of Advisors on
science and technology a couple members
of whom are here today issued a report
called renewing the promise it was one
of a pair of twin reports one viewed
from outside of government one from
inside of government of that vital
interface between the research
universities and the federal government
and the first recommendation in that
report was that the universities are
necessarily going to learn to live in
situations of constrained support where
in fact we're going to have to learn to
live with less some very difficult some
very wrenching decisions are going to be
required what it means is that even the
most prestigious university can no
longer expect to have departments in
every field of human activity nor are we
going to be able to have sub active
activity in the subfields of the
departments that remain and weak
departments are going to have to be
sacrificed in order to release the
resources necessary to keep those that
remain at a level of world-class
excellence and the three key words are
excellence selectivity to retain that
excellence and regional cooperation so
that students are not denied the variety
of
access to fields courses and activities
that they have become used to what it
means is that we have to cooperate with
other institutions on a regional basis
and be prepared to give credit to
activities in different institutions now
I think also one of our key problems is
that when the first flush of federal
funding arrived in the 1950s most of the
bridges that had been built over many
years between the research universities
and the private sector were burned with
considerable enthusiasm at the time the
idea was what the hell we go to lots of
money we don't need to worry about
anything and some terrible stereotypes
developed the folk in the private sector
understandably decided that the students
were left wing radicals that they would
much want anyway and the students
returned the favor by considering the
industrial leaders as money-grubbing
Philistines and that's the sort of
wonderful situation in which we've been
living for far too long the bridges are
being rebuilt at the moment and I'm all
for it it's far past the appropriate
time but there is a problem in most of
the nation's universities the focus in
this rebuilding process is on the
development of these cooperative
interactions as a mechanism to bring
industrial funding support to the
universities it is not what is on what
is vastly more important namely bringing
some real world experience exposure to
the universities so that the students
broaden their career horizons understand
what tremendous challenges and
opportunities there are outside the
normal academic confines and this report
that I just mentioned as one of its
other major recommendations said that
even though we're the
most mobile of all societies anywhere in
the planet we have to really increase
the amount of exchange because has been
said several times here today the only
way you transfer anything technology
knowledge experience is in the heads of
humans and we have to start exchanging
more people between our universities our
federal laboratories and Industry
because everyone will gain as we do that
and the real world input that can come
from bringing industrialists and
government folk into the major
universities to interact and it isn't
workable on an afternoon basis has to be
for a matter of days and weeks so that
people can get to know one another and
get to realize that the stereotypes that
I've just mentioned simply are that
they're stereotypes and they really have
to be wiped out now it's important too
that we begin to focus on the fact that
the average degree undergraduate or
graduate has a half-life that is
shrinking fast and that education must
be a lifelong activity and we haven't
done anywhere near as much as we should
have done or can do in making continuing
education not only convenient but
attractive the whole question of finding
out what the customer in industry wants
for continuing education we of them
means and the people facilities to
provide it but the conversation hasn't
really gone on adequately for this I'm
finding as a brand new dean of
engineering that a rather remarkable
thing about engineering project is that
the first 10% of the decisions commit
something like 90 percent of all the
resources that go into that project and
most engineers aren't very good at those
first 10
percent of the decisions they're great
on the other 90% of the nuts and bolts
the first 10% involved questions of
economics management ethics all sorts of
things that are not part of the
traditional engineering toolkit that I
think is a challenge that all of us
involved in education at the graduate
level and undergraduate have to take
seriously we have to prepare individuals
for leadership and for being able to
participate in those critical first 10%
of the decisions and let me also
emphasize that we have been singularly
ineffective as a political constituency
there has been an arrogance and a
tendency to believe that sooner or later
those folk in Washington would catch on
that what we were doing was so important
that they would fund it without any
effort on our part and without our
having to mess with that political stuff
which really is not all that pleasant if
that was ever true and I doubt it it
certainly isn't true now and the thing
that concerns me most is that there are
so many academics who go see their
senator or their representative only
when there is a crisis and that is not
going to work and I keep urging and have
been urging and will continue to urge in
whatever forum I have that it is vitally
important to make connections with your
representative and your senator when you
don't really want anything take them to
lunch you'll have a wonderful time he'll
be sliding forward or she will be
sliding forward on their chair because
they know that you're going to ask for
something and if you don't do it they
will be so damned amazed they will
remember you forever
this is critically important and just
the people in this room could make an
enormous difference in what the future
Congress this Congress one or forth is
going to do with respect to Science and
Technology if each one of you as a
constituent were to talk to your
representatives and your senators it's
one of the most important things you
could possibly do and one of the things
that all of us have tended to forget
both in government and in the
universities is what was learned way
back in 1946 when we started the whole
question of federal support of
universities namely that we were
involved in an investment not a
procurement and all too often we slip
back into the procurement idea we're
getting research done in a university
requires roughly the same paperwork as
buying a battleship and much of the same
intellectual content what we really need
to do is remember that we are not only
buying research and new knowledge young
people trained to use that knowledge but
we're also investing in a capability
which is unique in this country it's one
of the gems of this country and it's the
envy of the rest of the world that's the
entire research enterprise now we have
not yet either succeeded fully in
developing a new vision of why and what
and how research and development should
be done in this country and what's goal
should be the mission that was
articulated in Vannevar Bush's
remarkable book science the endless
frontier back in 1945 served us
astonishingly well for the last half of
the 20th century but it is certainly not
adequate for the 21st it's important to
recognize for example that Bush really
didn't even mention industry in any
substantial way in that report because
the assumption was that if the taxpayer
the universities that new knowledge and
trained young people would find their
way into industry in ways that need not
concern the federal government we know
of course that that is not the case now
a good start has been made in the
document that the Clinton administration
has produced the science for what is it
science for that's right you see I have
I have a small mental block about it now
let me finish having having raised a
whole series of depressing issues all of
which I believe to be very real let me
shift gears in closing and simply point
out that I really am remarkably
optimistic about our future as a nation
our future as a civilization our future
in science and technology and perhaps
the major reason for that is what I
think back to my graduation as a
fledgling engineer close to 50 years ago
I remember the television and
antibiotics were both laboratory
curiosities that polio stopped the
summer playgrounds and swimming pools so
the your parents had you hidden away for
the summer that the dc-3 was the
backbone of the transportation industry
that portable telecommunications
equipment was firmly in the domain of
Dick Tracy and that man in space was
science fiction now all of that has
changed and changed dramatically in 50
years and you would have to be vastly
more pessimistic than I am to conclude
that the next 50 years will not see
developments discoveries and surprises
that will make those of the last 50 pale
by comparison
and I conclude that those of us here
today are among the very fortunate few
in our race who have had the privilege
of being involved in the great adventure
that is science and technology thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much dr. Bromley and
we'll go on now to get the perspective
from John Armstrong who is well known I
know to the MIT audience because he's a
member of the visiting committee of the
physics department here and has has been
the chair of the NRC study on the future
of space science I've gotten to know dr.
Armstrong a bit in the past year so
partly is a consequence of the forum on
science and the national interest and
also as a consequence of his generous
donation of time and and thoughtfulness
to some of the proposals that were
trying to work together with you and
others on as you as many of you no doubt
know dr. Armstrong has recently retired
as the vice president of science and
technology from IBM where he had a very
distinguished career in research both in
terms of his own research interest
research productivity and as one of the
distinguished research managers and
leaders in this country and what was
then and continues to be one of the most
exciting industries of the recent past
and the foreseeable future I know he has
a great deal to say to us about how how
his perspective on graduate education
and the future of Science and Technology
has been shaped both by his own
experiences and by current events so I
won't stand in the way of his
presentation and give us an opportunity
to get on to the audience participation
and discussion that I really think we
need to have so John if I could get you
well thank you Marcy
thank you all for for being here
unlike unlike Alan I always try to do
what Chuck vest asked me to do so I am
going to try to comment more briefly
perhaps than I would have on graduate
education from the perspective of
industrial research my views on graduate
education and the ways in which it might
be improved have been formed during the
30 years in which I worked in industry
both as a practicing physical scientist
as a manager of all of the physical
science activity in IBM then as a
manager of engineers in development and
finally as director of research I think
the current situation in which jobs are
scarce in some parts of science and in
which as this symposium today shows we
are rethinking the whole a national
enterprise in science may add some
appropriateness to the views I'm about
to express but they basically are the
outcome of my experience now it will be
well known to this audience that many
engineering schools have spent a lot of
time recently reassessing their master's
degree science and engineering programs
and many many schools including MIT have
made significant changes in those
programs but there has been little a
little reassessment so far of the
underlying assumptions expectations and
requirements for PhD programs in science
and in engineering areas that are
closely related to science and in my
view it's time for such a reassessment
and indeed this session and some of the
comments today so
that others are of that view now I say
this despite the fact that as was
pointed out and I think very correctly
pointed out by dr. Bromley and by mr.
Vincent there is an enormous amount to
be proud of in the status the
achievements and the status of our
graduate education depending on the
particular field of science under
discussion somewhere between 40 and
perhaps up to 90% of new PhDs will end
up working in settings outside research
universities the presumption seems to
have been up to now that the process
which is was designed to train research
professors will do as well as can be
done in preparing graduates for
employment as science and engineering
PhDs in non-traditional roles that is
teaching in four-year colleges or doing
research in industry or working in
government for example or in many other
fields that have already been mentioned
today now clearly the traditional PhD
training training for research
professorships is not bad preparation
for the non-traditional roles we've
heard that said over and over again and
I've seen that in my own experience but
I think it can be done better and I
think the current national situation
requires that we think about how it may
be done better now I grant you that many
in many respects the PhD programs in
science and engineering are in good
shape the technical sophistication of
new graduates in their specialties is
usually breathtaking new PhD graduates
are still the best vehicles in the world
for technology transfer now actually
that's not quite right the best
technology transfer vehicle is a moving
van
the moving van which delivers the new
PhD to his or her first job or the
central research scientist to the
development laboratory or a researcher
from a national laboratory to industry
the key really is the movement the
serious movement of people but although
the graduates our graduate educational
system is clearly world class the envy
of the world I would say there are
serious problems as well
problems that I came to see over these
many years of hiring and managing new
PhDs now I don't have a lot of time so
I'm going to have to be brief and
therefore I will sound marginally more
dogmatic on these subjects then I feel
briefly it's my view that the training
of new PhDs in general is too narrow
intellectually to campus centered and
too long furthermore and perhaps this is
the most serious of all many new PhDs
have much too confined a set of personal
and career expectations and we just
heard that point from dr. Bromley the
narrow intellectual focus the over
specialization often has unfortunate
consequences in my experience for the
new scientist view of him or herself
this over specialization results or can
result in a lack both of perspective and
of self-confidence they often believe
themselves
ill-prepared to venture outside their
specialties to use their powerful
training in jobs in development or
manufacturing or technical management or
government the burden of over
specialization is compounded by their
often total lack of work experience
outside the university
during their PhD and by a culture which
still all too often suggests that
becoming like their professor represents
real success now that's my point about
to narrow intellectually now this point
about to campus send to campus centered
now this parrot this paradoxical
situation that seems to me is due in
part to the lack of serious requirements
for scientific and technical breadth in
the typical graduate curriculum and it's
compounded by the fact that there's
little or no encouragement and a lot of
implicit discouragement for a young
person who wants to spend time during
graduate school off campus in a setting
where technical knowledge is actually
used to do so there is in short almost
no value assigned to technical breath or
real-world experience as an essential
part of PhD training to narrow
intellectual aid to campus centered now
too long I firmly believe that that an
average of six or in many cases seven
years an average of six or seven years
is too long it's a disservice to the
students it costs the country more money
for the training of scientists than it
need to and I hold that view at the same
time that I have this view that Pete the
young people as part of their training
would be better served if they were able
to spend some time away from campus and
I see no contradiction between spending
between shortening the time on average
to obtain a PhD and spending more time
away from campus as part of the training
the time it takes to get a PhD does not
depend very strongly if at all on how
much scientific knowledge the world has
achieved the
I think on a linear combination of how
long it takes to acquire the currently
selected subset of scientific knowledge
that's thought to be needed on how long
it takes to produce genuine novel
research results and how long it takes a
young person can mature intellectually I
simply don't believe that that time
needs to be six or seven years on I
think it's a serious disservice to young
people to keep them close toward that
long or to allow themselves to cloister
themselves that long now I've made this
particular comment to a lot of graduate
students over the last two years I've
been spending time with graduate
students and not once has any graduate
student denied that long stays in
graduate school are partly due both to
the students comfort with graduate
student life and to their anxiety about
what it will be like in the outside
world when they leave this combination
of comfort and anxiety I book pens I
believe to make PhD training take longer
than necessary this is possible of
course because the funding agencies and
the research universities allow such
long stays I believe that's experienced
out in the world of technical work
during graduate studies will
significantly lower the typical graduate
student anxiety level about finding a
career in getting a job and will then
the offenders shorten the actual time to
the degree on average I have lots of
anecdotal evidence of that I think it
would be worth studying seriously
and shortening the time to the PhD will
also saddle the new graduates with less
of a disadvantage with respect to their
contemporaries who are years ahead in
experience and seniority in the
workplace now what can industry do to
help it can and should be responsive to
setting up PhD cooperative arrangements
with engineering research departments
excuse me with science and engineering
departments
I believe that small firms and startups
have the most to gain by such
arrangements and also the most to give
students in the way of broad perspective
many of our graduate schools are
surrounded by such small companies many
which have started at from university
science and engineering programs however
except for the students of the faculty
directly involved these exciting firms
are tend to be invisible to the majority
of graduate students well I want to
finish very quickly here with a few
perhaps practical suggestions if PhD
training although it is the envy of the
world is still too narrow intellectually
to campus entered and too long
what might be some helpful
countermeasures I've suggested some and
I think there are steps that the
Faculty's funding agencies and employers
could all take faculties should give
serious attention to reinvigorating a
requirement for a minor as part of a PhD
and make sure that the minor can be
satisfied in ways that truly supplement
the traditional programs this includes
the creation of new science courses at
the interfaces between traditional
disciplines as well as the encouragement
to take courses in other departments and
faculties faculties can devote serious
effort to forming those contacts outside
the university that can be turned into
internships summer employments and other
away from campus experience for graduate
students and departments could use a
larger proportion of their visitors
budget on scientists and engineers from
outside academia who can provide
real-world non-academic perspective the
point that dr. Bromley just made funding
agencies I think should ask grant
applications about their success in
providing real world experience for
graduate students and give some modest
credit in evaluating grants based on
success in this area Institute
mechanisms and procedures which
discourage continued funding of graduate
students past say some average number of
years you pick the number I would pick
five-and-a-half years on an average I
think the funding agencies could
adiabatically alter the balance between
fellowships and traineeships on the one
hand and research assistantships on the
other with the aim of doubling the
fraction of the former over a several
year period employers can do a number of
things to help first they should make
serious efforts to accommodate summer
interns co-op students and make a effort
make sure that the job assignments
really stretch the technical horizons of
students they should be much more open
to the advantage of encouraging their
R&D staff to spend time as academic
visitors part of the reason is so little
of that now is that people in industry
don't think it's worth their time 3 and
this is in many ways the most important
thing industry should make the
considerable effort required to improve
their hiring strategies and their
competence in hiring so that they can
correctly value the fantastic general
capability that is part of the hit that
a new PhD comes with and make a much
stronger effort to 4 see how bringing
such people in will provide the
flexibility that as mr. Vincent pointed
out goes with 40 years of employment
I believe that although we have the best
graduate education and science and
engineering in the world by far the
situation into which our country is
moving demands that we think of ways in
which to make it ever more effective
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
this has certainly been a provocative
set of presentations this afternoon and
I would like to I know some of you in
the audience are going to be sorely
tempted to rush out to other obligations
but I think that would be a real shame
since the topic of education and how we
maintain the infrastructure is so
important to the future to our future
success both economically in terms of
generating knowledge so if the rest of
the panel would come to the table here
I'm going to forego my own personal
remarks on the grounds that no professor
certainly not one that's been in
government for a year and a half is
capable of shortening her remarks from
the usual 50 minutes to 50 seconds with
any reasonable sensibilities well all
for a few there are only three chairs
well weel there are three chairs yes
Sheila Sheila Sheila has come up with
the innovative solution its
characteristic of women great are there
questions from the audience well if
they're not quite if there's other
questions for the audience let me let me
pose pose one suggestion and I have an
in in all fairness to my colleagues in
the NSTC process I will unveil that this
idea has begun to generate within the
context of the Committee on health
safety and food which had a follow-on
forum this past year and is working on a
document one of the topics it focused
one of the subgroups focused on in
health safety and food was preparing the
next generation of scientists and what
kinds of training programs and what
kinds of where we were going with
respect to sustaining an interest in
science and bringing new investigators
into the field and an idea that's sort
of beginning to build and that seems to
be a theme that I hear here as well is
whether or not it would be productive
for a group like this and I think many
of you are exactly the leaders that
would be necessary for this those in
industry those in our research
university
and those who are interested in in
education as faculty members and others
to think about putting together
something my something one might
whimsically called a partnership for a
new generation of scientists now that's
just a whimsical title it's a little
little perhaps a little hokey but
nonetheless it might build on the ideas
that some of the some folks we're
talking about today of how it is we
might bring together the coalition
that's necessary to help us broaden the
definition of what constitutes a
scientist for the future and also at the
same time to talk about the important
questions of both undergraduate and
graduate education so I just put that
out as an idea I think that part of what
is necessary to make the scientific
industrial and academic community and
government community a coherent force
for positive change for the future are a
few ideas or projects that could become
joint a joint effort and if we can't
agree on some areas of priorities it
seems we can all agree on the critical
importance of sustaining our leadership
in science and producing science and
scientists and engineers for the future
and the incredibly critical importance
to the nation of developing a workforce
that has a scientific has scientific
knowledge and I said literacy and which
does not which spreads the scientific
knowledge and interest and understanding
through a broad spectrum of our
population and is not just confined to
those who will discover knowledge for
the future but is supported by those who
would appreciate and use the knowledge
that is generated by those who have been
leading the fields so on that note I'll
just stop and ask if maybe if nobody if
there aren't any questions maybe our
panelists could add their ideas or tell
me this is a terrible idea or respond to
this
you know I identified with what you're
suggesting for graduate education and
being someone who's in charge of
graduate students clearly have to deal
with these issues I believe but it's
very difficult to have a meaningful
relationship between industry and a
academic research community exchanges
are easy conversations for two hours or
tributes on a meaningful relationship
out of the graduate programs you've been
developed with to people out of 30 per
year so let me ask you in your own
career did you have a meaningful
relationship with industry before you
joined IBM yes that's one of the reasons
I feel so strongly about it
and it's one of the reasons I shall I
put this that I that I turned out better
than I might have having spent 12 years
in one academic institution where the
possibility of a career in industry was
never or let's say in the undergraduate
part of it never mentioned I had the
great good fortune of spending four
summers at the GE Research Lab back in
the 50s just marvelous and then a summer
when I was in graduate school at Lincoln
labs so I had five accumulation of five
different experiences of how scientists
behave and how that all worked to sort
of help me see just what becoming the
mature scientist was like it was a
fabulous opportunity and let me pick up
on one one thing you suggested I don't I
don't make this suggestion of off-campus
experience with the idea that it should
be a required part of every graduate
students life that's just not I'm even
if it were desirable which I suppose
it's not it's not practical but it ought
to be it ought to be viewed as a very
valuable additional way to get
first-class
preparation as a scientist and it ought
to be available for those students and
you know so that's the way I would think
about it it's not not a across-the-board
requirement that's hopeless but it
shouldn't be something which is
discouraged and there are funding agency
impediments to doing that and there are
university impediments to graduate
students getting away and it ought to be
possible to have a bad as part of your
career switching careers from science to
whatever is available now and I was just
wondering if anybody has considered the
long-term implications of the in some
fields large body of people are having
trouble moving out and doing other
things and what can be done to take care
of the negative long term implications
of that well my view and I'm sure
everyone else has a view of that my view
is not that we are training too many but
say physicists but that we have we they
tend to have for obvious reasons that I
tried to explain to narrow uh view of
what they can do and what that's
exciting to do and university
departments tend to know less than they
need to know about these possibilities
so you know there's lots of room for
improvement there let me add just in one
luster of example I have a graduate
student some years back who is now on
Wall Street not because he needed to be
in any sense because he wanted to be but
we had lunch recently for which
naturally he paid
I asked them how the hell is it that
you're really remarkably successful here
what I know probably better than your
mother that you know nothing about
economics and nothing about
international relations and in fact
nothing that I can conceive of that is
abuse to you here his his answer was
short succinct and probably absolutely
correct it was I'm a hell of a lot
smarter than these guys that can work
both ways a lot of people don't really
want to be let me follow up on that it's
not I'm sure that Alan's former student
is smarter than then you might be
smarter than some of those other
colleagues but part it's sort of it's
part of the paradox of getting a PhD in
science you do something very
specialized in the process you get as an
intellectual armamentarium of enormous
general utility what's what I'm really
complaining about in part of my talking
is that on average neither the students
nor their professors value that general
capability and that is a great failing
of the of the intellectual establishment
the university establishment a great
failing let me just pick up a little
once more on that one of the things that
I think is of greatest importance is the
fact that during a proper PhD education
the one thing that the individual gets
is a sense of confidence that they can
tackle problems that no one else has
ever tackled before and do it
successfully that's something that's
worth any amount when you go out trying
to address in fact the problems of
greatest importance to our society today
well having said that it was mentioned
several times here today and passed over
quickly I think too quickly that the
time has come
to take another look at the PhD the
first one was awarded in this country in
1861 nothing has changed
of any consequence since then and
there's something good about that
but on the other hand a lot of people
are going into careers particularly
today that simply do not require the
experience of 3-4 years of original
research they're never going to do
original research in the rest of their
life this really is a waste of their
time we in the academic community should
be thinking about alternative ways to
educate young people for the kind of
career trajectories that we're probably
going to be there well one of the
reasons I thought it might be useful to
put the groups of the undergraduate and
graduate is together is because we are
primarily talking about education at
least for the evenings of this
afternoon's purposes in research
universities and I think when we talk
about how do you get graduate students
to think about the future you ought to
be talking about what you're doing the
undergraduate level as well and one of
the ways to reform graduate education is
to think about what we are requiring of
undergraduates as they come to graduate
graduate education because the
opportunity to broaden their horizons
for them to have some experience in
industry for them to think about the the
reason they're going to graduate school
in a broader way could be shaped at
least partly at the undergraduate level
it's a little bit like you know whatever
the requirements you have for entrance
determine a bit of the product you're
going to get at the end as well as at
the end at the intake level so one of
the things that I think Sheila's
comments were particularly helpful to is
to talk about you know what is this pool
of people we are recruiting in some of
the people we are not recruiting in
right now may be better able to do some
of these other tasks than some of the
traditional students that we've brought
in I don't know that that's true but it
seems a reasonable question for
educators and those who are training the
21st century people to think about the
sharply and thank you for turning back
to me but the it
graduate education in science limits the
number and kind of people who are
willing to study science and that you
know takes us back to the issue of
scientific knowledge if we expect a
larger number of well-educated people to
experience to learn to have more
scientific knowledge we've got to convey
the value of that to people not going on
to graduate school in the field and I
agree entirely that it's the valuing and
the way that faculty communicate to
their very first year students whom
they're looking forward to seeing in the
second year that feeds this Sun this
narrow route into graduate school they
are linked we have to three more
questions and then Ernie you want to
open it up in the general way okay you
have a church which showed the ten
occupations that had something to do
with science and I was astonished in
your assumption that you seemed to
convey to me anyway that the discovery
of knowledge which was I out number one
was the only one of those for which a
PhD seem to be appropriate whereas it
seemed to me that you go three-quarters
the way down the left and your first
term people could make very substantial
and meaningful contributions to all of
those things having to do with science
and when in fact use their talents quite
effectively no it wasn't not I think I
cried too much to that it wasn't that
you wouldn't need that level of
knowledge to contribute
it was the valuing issue that John has
now articulated for us that these
youngsters going through the ph.d
program are given to understand that
they are being trained to discover new
knowledge and if they find themselves
doing something else it will be
something lesser that that's the the
meaning of that then there's a lot more
to do in science than merely discovering
new knowledge that's the point I'm sorry
I made it unclear
Peter said Peter I've got the lights in
my eyes here
yes I'm a little concerned again by this
paradox on the one hand we claim we have
this high-performing system on the other
hand we claim it's missing the mark
Locke and I think there's a consensus on
both issues that suggests to me that we
might try to look at what the difference
is between the form of our system and
the actual content we've talked before
about the absence of measures are we
really producing a good product
in fact for is it a blessing or a
certificate that is accepted and is
qualitative self-consistency valued as
opposed to what it actually is capable
of doing in reality one of the things
that I've been finding is I talked to
people in universities about these
issues and let's take the issue of real
life experience as part of your training
time and time again it turns out that
that faculties will say well we could do
something like that of course it won't
be a PhD it will be a doctor of this or
it'll be a whatever of that and you know
that that raises this issue of the you
know getting your tickets for I think I
think it's for industry is to try to pay
some attention to that and I don't know
any practical way to deal with that in
the abstract I don't know how to solve
that problem in principle I know how to
solve it in practice if we had more of
this interaction that we've that Alan
mentioned that I've been talking about
it would be solved in in in practice and
we wouldn't have to solve it in
principle what but you're absolutely
right I I have that was a big problem in
managing the hiring of PhDs especially
in development but even even in research
was that people would go for the
unerringly for the specialist who's the
the lifetime of who specially was
half-life was you know three years it's
it's it's lazy its laziness on the part
of the employers and also a lack of
intellectual confidence in being able to
judge on the part of employers it's a
lot more work to hire somebody who isn't
a specialist than who you know but whose
smartest smartest damn guy that came
along or girl that came along that's a
lot more work and it's more risk john do
you uh in the day we were talking about
the the fact that we have to change the
way we talk about the research
enterprise that some of the models that
sort of implied even though i think many
of us have thought about them never saw
them as linear but they implied to
people who don't understand the nuances
a sort of linear model is there do i
understand what you're saying to also
potentially lead to a reintegration of
the types of education that our
institutions of higher learning may be
giving as well i mean one of the things
that we may be missing as a futuristic
opportunity or that universities may
have to think about is whether their
educational role is really over when
they chuck them through the linear
process and we throw out a PhD maybe
there ought to be some ways to select
those specialized PhDs that do go out
they really ought to get some business
training or they ought to get some legal
training and the institutions from
whence they come ought to have or moving
out the specific ones but those kinds of
institutions ought to have a more open
and better relationship for retraining
recycling re-educating we're focusing a
lot on that in the job training programs
at K through twelve you know ready jobs
ready you know work to school to work
programs and retraining and retooling
for a lower level of education but the
concept it seems to me is one if we're
gonna get into a debate about what
constitutes higher education or what
constitutes a high level degree maybe we
ought to be thinking about if we want
leaders if we want there to be more than
five PhDs and as corporate officers at
Ford and other places what is the other
kind of training those folks will have
to have
and when in their life will they have to
have it in order to have a successful
multiple opportunity career having come
from an institution where I must tell
you personally I thought several times
about going back to law school or going
to business school or going to medical
school you wonder if there's not some
way we shouldn't be doing that as
institutions of higher education as well
so just as a thought maybe that may be
the model of thinking about how we train
people to be the leaders of the futures
got to be changed too that's part of
what I had in mind by suggesting a
serious minor or other attempts to get a
broader maybe you should not always be
done in graduate school maybe it oughta
wait till somebody figures out of our
our research staff these days we'll go
to business school get some business
trained some feel about it so I'm a
little bit worried that you know people
can broaden themselves after graduate
school to the important thing to by
graduate school is learning to solve a
problem and what it means is all from
that's what graduate school was about at
one stage I mean least thesis theses
were about does it understand when
you've done something when you haven't
done it
be teaching people to think clearly and
things like that those are the things
that I consider to be the most important
the broadening aspect of things in some
ways is something we can take care of
well yes and no bill that is I certainly
agree that that the overwhelmingly
important job is to is to learn how to
learn in that deep deep way no question
about it and and what I'm asserting is
that ability to learn how to learn and
health have self-confidence and
perspective on how you can apply that is
helped by some broadening I found an
awful lot of scientists that is this was
a terrible blow to me when I finally
discovered I thought an awful lot of
scientists weren't interested in nature
or they really had no no sort of notion
that they ought to be able to move
broadly in the world of science and and
other Affairs so as far as getting you
know an MBA or something I agree if you
want to do that do it later but you know
studying only quantum field theory can
be injurious to your psychological
health it seems to me I like the whole
idea of and ending on the note that's
studying too much quantum field theory
can be bad for years
will truly appreciate this but I'll turn
the podium back over to tebab who I
think has a few words for us before we
adjourn thank you again
they speakers into the audience
[Applause]
poor old Bob Jaffe whose chair of our
faculty who spent his life on quantum
field theory just had a nervous
breakdown I think oh yeah and my field
got declared dead anyway so at least
Bob's gonna ultimately figure out how
much I weigh and why manifestly because
of the hour won't surprise you that
we're going to pass on the open
discussion much of which we just had we
therefore have to pass on my
introduction of Ernie Moniz but let me
just say briefly that Ernie whose head
of physics played a central role in fact
was the key person in putting together
today's program so we're really grateful
for that he also as you heard earlier
from Jack Gibbons played a crucial role
as a consultant to OSTP in constructing
the science in the national interest
document so we really owe a great debt
to him Jack also asked how he managed to
do this and run the physics department
actually he didn't run the physics
department that was the answer actually
Elizabeth Cooper his financial assistant
or administrative assistant runs the
physics department I also before
introducing Chuck want to thank a lot of
the people involved in the organization
of this event today most especially
Sarah Carruthers my assistant dean for
development who played a central role
and the staff of the industrial liaison
program a number of whom too many to
name actually but who are really crucial
in making all of this work as well as it
did so finally I want to turn over to
the hero of the day Chuck vest who
actually was down at wah she was on a
plane at 6 o'clock in the morning going
to Washington which is the typical day
for Chuck came back and is I know going
to give us a brilliant summary of the
day's events chuck is the 15th president
of MIT one of the most high-profile
presidents we've ever had and it played
a really important role in leadership in
Washington as we heard earlier in the
day and also an equally important role
in leadership here at MIT and were very
proud of him his only defect is that
he's not a product of MIT he actually
came from Michigan but Michigan seems to
have a good track record
and producing great university
presidents so we accept him on that
basis
[Applause]
flattery will get you everywhere Bob as
we end the day I'm left with a mystery
it's this why is it that out of this
entire assembly the only person who does
what I tell him is John Armstrong yep
Anita Jones has an admiral to change her
slides I had originally intended I had
originally intended to introduce today's
session and I had put together a few
succinct headlines that I thought
painted a picture of the state of
science policy and the things we should
be debating but now I'm going to give
them as a summary of the day completely
uninformed or encumbered by anything
that occurred nonetheless I think they
will work and fortunately for you they
will in fact be brief a few headlines
first on the political situation on the
universities and finally on the national
R&D system politically clinton
administration ran on a platform that
gave strong emphasis to technology the
science drivers of our economy and keen
and very important investments for the
future as you know they released two
major policy statements technology for
america's economic growth and science in
the national interest science the
national interests of course called for
a shared commitment among government
industry and universities it's a well
received policy document that can form
the basis of a national commitment to
science is being essential for the
development of a vibrant future
yesterday the president released a
budget for university research science
technology and civilian technology
development that is strong
relative to the rest of the domestic
discretionary budget includes increases
of 7% and government-wide academic
research three and a half percent in
civilian basic research an 8% in
government-wide applied research we may
not care for the exact titles we may
wish there were more but it is certainly
strong in comparison to what's happening
in much of the rest of the budget even
at this stage the new congressional
leadership of course indicates that
dramatic cuts are going to need to be
made across domestic discretionary
accounts which include all of the
agencies that fund research the
exception of DoD the pressure to reduce
all domestic discretionary spending
including the future of science
technology and education are certainly
expected to continue for the next
several years the new congressional
leadership states that federal that the
federal government should support basic
research and universities they appear to
be energizing a bipartisan commitment to
bear it to merit-based grant and
contract awards and strongly opposing
academic earmarking there's a lot of
sentiment running abroad today that
investments in such programs as the ATP
TRP SEMATECH are not appropriate uses of
federal support in my view there's a
particular danger that we all have to
worry about and that is in opposition to
such programs which are increasingly as
we've heard today being called applied
research may inadvertently generate
budget cuts to many extremely important
activities in engineering and applied
research completely unintentionally
there's also some sentiment abroad that
DoD should stop funding basic research
which i think would be a very very
disastrous occurrence for the nation the
cancellation of the superconducting
supercollider still reverberates as a
symbol of our national inability to keep
large-scale multi-year commitments you
diversity 'he's the Halos of our
research universities were indeed
tarnished by events such as the Dingell
hearings and the uses of indirect cost
they have not recovered in the eyes of
many in Congress and in the press
despite sustained hard work by many to
improve the system including the new
proposals just published by the Clinton
administration in the Federal Register
universities have found themselves
continually on the defensive they've
hosted innumerable auditors
investigators on their campuses and have
fought for four years to stop various
attempts for federal shifting of
research costs to other revenue sources
tuition income gifts endowment and state
support
despite this the Clinton administration
and the Bush administration before it
maintained extremely open and meaningful
dialogue within the university community
on policy issues and we're very grateful
and I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank both Jack Gibbons and Allan
Bromley personally for that fact
America's universities has been said
today remain a precious national asset
combining great and varied intellectual
capacity the responsibility for the
education of our next generation they
must however recognize the seismic
changes in their environment we must
strive to get their costs under control
and remain affordable the role in the
future of America's science strategy
must be clarified their federal support
whatever it's going to be needs to be
stabilized and finally the National Rd
system in order to become
internationally competitive in this
complicated environment most large
companies have transformed their
research and development organizations
into groups that focus on reduction of
products cycle times improvement of
quality another critically important but
nonetheless near-term go
consequently and there may be arguments
about this much of our important mid to
long term research that is a prime
source of innovation and the future
products has been eliminated
in short the system that couples much
fundamental research to ultimate
commercial application I think is in
danger of rapid disintegration industry
is not doing the job universities from
National Laboratories are not doing them
either nor have they been chartered or
funded to do so so it seems to me that
we are faced in a situation where
elements of our national innovation
system especially companies are making
locally optimal decisions but as their
developments become increasingly
near-term and protected as important
intellectual property the shared
scientific and technological knowledge
advances that make the entire system
progress or in danger
science generally has enjoyed strong and
nonpartisan support for half a century
as the nation grapples with the
overriding budget issues and
dramatically new international
environment in which we operate we must
strive to retain this support and it's
non partisan nature as leaders of
government industry and academia we must
build a strong mutually supportive
system for scientific advancement and
technological innovation that serves the
national interest in both the near and
long-term that I believe was the context
in which we decided to organize today's
symposium I must say the conversation
has been a bit gentler than I predicted
or than perhaps might have been
desirable nonetheless I think a lot of
wisdom and insight has been displayed
and I think all of us are returning to
our respective venues with a lot of new
things to think about and more
importantly still to join forces across
cultures to to work on so I want simply
to thank all of you for your attendance
and I particularly Jack want to thank
you for bringing so many members of the
Clinton administration who we know are
exceedingly busy at this time to come
here to Cambridge on this cold day to
tell us what's happening what your
perspectives are to engage in
interchange with us I want to state on
behalf of all of the organizers here
that it was extremely rewarding to get
so many ready and immediate yeses to the
people that we called from industry and
from other universities to join together
in today's symposium it's been a long
day I thank all of you for your
participation and I truly hope that this
will be not an end in itself but really
will be a beginning toward increasing as
someone has said the national interest
in science so that science and the
national interest can progress thank you
very much
[Applause]